One benefit of the algorithm
we've developed is that it
is highly generalizable.
It does not depend on working
only in three dimensions.
In fact, just by changing the word
plane in our algorithm to the word line
we can immediately use the code to solve
systems of equations in two dimensions.
On the other hand,
this algorithm will allow us to work
with higher dimensional
systems of equations too.
Recall that a two dimensional
plane in 3 dimensions
is defined by a single linear
equation in 3 variables.
If we move to end dimensions a similar
notion is called a hyperplane.
Which is defined by a single
linear equation with n variables.
The geometry of higher
dimensional objects,
even though we can't visualize
them in three dimensional space,
is analogous to the geometry
we've studied so far.
As with lines and planes, a hyperplane
in n dimensions is an (n-1)-dimensional
object and it can be specified by
a normal vector and a base point.
Also like lines and planes
the coefficients of the variables in
the equation have a normal vector for
the higher dimensional hyperplane.
And we need at least n
different hyperplanes and
n dimensions in order to obtain
a unique intersection point.
Most importantly Gaussian elimination
works just as well on systems of
equations in more than three variables
as it does with just two and
three variables.
Similar to the line in
plain classes we created,
let's now create a hyperplane class.
To make it, I almost literally copy and
paste my code for the plain object
just replacing all instances of
the word plane with hyperplane.
The only other change I need to make
is in the initializer function.
Here, since the hyperplane could
live in an arbitrary dimension.
I'm adding an optional parameter,
dimension, to the list of arguments.
If both the dimension and the normal
vector are missing in the initializer
call, then I can't figure out which
dimension is being asked for, so
I raise an exception.
Otherwise, I either set the normal
vector to be all zeros in the given
dimension or
I set the dimension to be the dimension
of the normal vector given.
And that's pretty much it.
Going back to the linear system class
after importing the hyperplane class
from my hyperplane module, and
without changing any of the code
in my linear system class.
I can now build a linear
system out of hyperplanes and
as long as the dimensions of each
hyperplane in a system are the same
it will work as expected.
Here I have a system of lines,
here I have a system of planes, and
here I have a system of four dimensional
hyperplanes in five dimensional space.
And running the code I obtain
parameterizations of the solutions for
each of the systems, or I'm told that
the system doesn't have a solution.